so what was the transition well for me I
don't I just remember like for example
with my gap
I wanted braces like a crazy person I
kept asking constantly constantly
constantly but then I remember
distinctly I went to get my senior
portrait pictures for high school taken
the photographer we would be talking in
between shots I'd be laughing and be
like haha bright smiling right like wide
you can see my gap and then as soon as
he would point the camera to shoot I
would close my mouth and have this like
some fake smile on my face that was
hiding my gap and I have so many
pictures of myself like that growing up
when my mom would smile Oh smile and I'd
be like he was like how come every time
you smile you close your mouth like that
finally I said you know I don't like my
gap and he just said to me he was like I
think you have a beautiful smile
and it's not the first time I'd ever
heard that but for some reason when he
said it I heard it in a new way for the
first time I just started smiling all
the times like I just started smiling
and I'd be saying as I was like I have a
beautiful smile I have a beautiful smile
it's sometimes hard for me to like smize
and be like I'm like I want a smile cuz
I feel like I'm making up for lost
smiles there were so many years that
little girl did not because she felt
like she was less than and she is not